go downstairs no bind you behind you
behind you behind ya through that door
okay and then I'm wrong no I'm wrong ha
ha God it was the door Castle each other
kill them kill them dead
stab them piranhas be able to kill each
other are you oh you're the last we're
trying just kill each other I shot you
Bob burden people right there it's India
Oh Orson oh yeah okay market you to kill
India these guys understand it's means a
gun here I got the gun died are you suck
okay so what happened I've also thing
what I'm not sure huh Wow glad I did
quickly we need a smaller how did you
hear the gun again that sucks what is
the dormice I'm in whoa you are a
bystander ah Oh get out of me Oh happen
help me go Oh bonus that's what a
murderer all right tango I run for the
gun too so by process of elimination
never saw the murderer all right I know
it's one of those shoes I'm blind
all right I'm jumping I'll just sit here
wait life he sucks
my house and we just go explore the
house and see if we break it yeah yeah I
guess if you were gonna get out
have you all crouch-jump you will
eventually get out of that right you
know that oh yeah gotcha strumpet risky
oh never mind just kill him okay I think
there is a but I think this Matt might
have some issues how do we get first
time then I think we needed a map all
right say that oh oh forward Ron don't
idiot or old forward okay what am i
alright hold on oh honey for me now who
got I got oh I'm the murderer we have
inside you have yes I think I need a pic
like office I don't care do something it
is what I would we'll wait a minute the
magic happen alright I should be done
sending client info by then okay I'm not
in I'm in in : yeah we're all a hey Doc
core is slow why is it glowing it's this
st. Patrick's Day because everyone's
wearing a green shirt oh come on
something you can't let her find me Oh
God yuck it's going free were just
standing there staring oh yeah nice
Haitian feeling better Marc I'm innocent
now I don't who are you who which one
not Lima boom where's Theo getting the
gun yeah I've got ways body I could have
the gun Andrew
got you got the gun back we were what's
happening I like I like I like how
you're doing to his body they're hanging
out I'm gonna shoot it at all
wait I don't I don't I did not get the
gun back someone else got the gun oh
yeah get it oh I guess shoot him again
shrim again haha guys rastelli
body here get up no no I gotta I gotta
get young wait
well sure but we're here and no stacked
over here was fine
Oh mom I've got a mud say to my face
it's me wide girder armed um no you know
I'm right here yeah are you right here
hey hi how's it goin he's gonna shoot it
with the waiter just change skincare we
ki right there what the hell have we
been playing murder that long and we did
not know that
guys I think Yami's the murderer I think
you know when alpha man must use weapons
I'll use the office I think it's tango
oh no no no I think I first I just want
to have a weapon please no wait he's a
murderer that's a trick cuz it's a
little trick ah I promise I'm Clara and
I'm trustworthy no no no here's my me
cheers gonna murder me help help help
run again the long hallway car house one
day close enough no no God no I'm simple
cons guys uniform
oh my god why do you have to leave me on
like that why'd you have to do that
couple crumbs on your shell
come on my god hello hi hi hey we're
good
whoa we made a trust packed oh yeah
Romeo we don't trust you
follow me we're good over here who has
the gun those Romeo oh and I never I am
a Romeo are you Romeo looking at two
people yeah yeah okay get over it get
over here get over here okay get over
here and as a maniac with a gun I think
their mother were the first person I see
there's a lot over there that's not good
yeah
Bobby are you alive Kelly there's a
murderer
there's a god it's so doing the opposite
stop moving wait moving it'll be okay oh
he's only shooting cuz you're moving
we're good okay Jia me yeah yeah
come come out in the hallway I'm on your
team oh yeah they both have guns no ah
good good yeah I have a gun that means
one of you is the murder murder sorry
are you the whole time your sweat it's
foreplay okay you're all here's what
planet-- we're gonna go over there and
we're each gonna shoot one running wind
running went down in the officers we're
gonna win wait we turn it off ourselves
good chance of killing the murderer oh
yeah earning waits running good story
inning I've got her
please down Branagh's the other way I
swear damn it yes would you kill two
people there hands in the air
hey you pocket there was a 66% chance
you were the murderer mark huh that's
not so goddamn it